hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ich habe euch mal wieder gesagt
hey ich habe er gesagt ich hab' ich
gesagt schick mir auf twitter mal wieder
videos ein wie ihr irgendwas macht und
darauf reagiere ich jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da muss ich wirklich sagen mega respekt
dafür ich habe mehr respekt vor allen
leuten irgendwelche instrumente spielen
können weil ich mir gerade selber
klavier beibringen und das ist schon ein
bisschen schwierig also ich meine alle
meine entchen und so kann ich jetzt
spiel und ein bisschen fett und ein
bisschen lot to learn oder so heißt aber
jetzt keine krassen teile mit
irgendwelchen akkorden die waren noch
nebenbei mit der linken hand drückt also
das ist mir gerade also bis sie zu viel
aber leute wenn ihr zeit habe bringt
euch ein instrument bei das ist das
schönste was es gibt auf der welt wenn
man instrument spielen kann also ohne
spaß meinen vollsten respekt für diese
aktion ich muss wirklich sagen wenn du
da ist irgendwas hingeschrieben hättest
was würde ich da machen und pds
vielleicht hin malen oder so kann ich
gesagt vollkommen ort lorig genauso
gemacht aber du hast dort meinen
instagram verlinkt den instagram kommt
luca dafür gibt es von mir auf jeden
fall den gewinn der woche hat er mir
gerade ernsthaften video geschickt wo er
sein kissen auf dem sofa geschmissen hat
ja er hat nicht ernsthaft video
geschickt weil er seinen kasten gegen
ein sofa geworfen hat und damit herzlich
willkommen hier wieder zuschauer wenn
sie das erste mal heute einschalten
einer ausgabe luca reagiert so sehen
videos nämlich teilweise ja immer aus
teilweise immer wahrscheinlich oder luca
ich versuche das ganze video jetzt mal
nachzustellen ich weiß das ist wirklich
systematisch und zynisch ich weiß es
doch für die produktion dieses videos
eigentlich ein riesiges produktionsteam
benötigen würde
die lightning übernehmen die regie
übernehmen
die keine ahnung hätte ring die stars
alles was man halt für so einen krassen
hollywood streifen wirklich braucht das
habe ich jetzt allerdings alles hier
leider nicht am start ich versucht video
trotzdem jetzt mal nachzustellen
ich habe ich gesagt ich krieg dich so
krass hin wie her aber ich glaube es war
schon nah dran so leute das hier ist ein
video vom movie park von dem xxl über
day wo unter anderem max sättel jahren
und auch ich waren und das ist jetzt
gerade ein video wo max glaube ich
versuchte bottle flip hinzukriegen ich
kenne max relativ gute kriegt eigentlich
immer worte 14
[Musik]
egal warum enttäuscht mich denn jetzt so
machen wer weiß schon dass ich ihn nach
holz anprangern will
warum warum kriege ich sowas eingesendet
ich muss wirklich sagen wir nicht so
unter den hashtag kugel das sind
natürlich auch ein paar videos wo leute
sich wirklich mühe gegeben haben und
wirklich auch darunter geschrieben am
hey du sagst ja immer hier kommt er nur
scheiße
wir machen jetzt ein vernünftiges da
bekomme ich sie auf videos wo leute
beispielsweise schaffen beziehungsweise
allgemein tanzen die leute irgendwas
auftreten machen aber die packen immer
musik im hintergrund wo ich direkt ins
claim für kriege das kann ich nicht rein
nebenleute da dürfen sie nicht sein wenn
ich das nicht rein nehme ich bin
wirklich immer auf der sicheren seite
wenn ich videos rein nehme wie
beispielsweise wenn jemand sein kissen
ebenso gegen schmeißt oder klopapier
oder wenn jemand max filmen oder
irgendwie so sachen wo ihr die
kompletten rechte daran habt habe auch
an dieser stelle muss ich wieder ganz
ehrlich sagen meine damen und herren
dieses video hat mich sehr berührt was
wir hier gerade hier eigentlich gesehen
habe ich bin übrigens zu haben für
keyframes deswegen mache ich das gerade
mit meiner kamera ich versuche jetzt
auch dieses video ohne produktionsteam
ohne professionelle leute die mir dabei
helfen jetzt in die tat umzusetzen das
heißt sie sind es jetzt eingeblendet wie
ich dieses video hier nach stellen würde
ich weiß ich weiß licht war nicht
perfekt ich hab's probiert freunde
[Musik]
seitdem ich jetzt alle zwei drei tagen
instagram livestream macht übrigens ich
heiße dort stehen instagram dem ich dort
in letzter zeit ein bisschen mehr live
stream mache ich das ja oft so dass ich
über irgendwas erzählen was ich gerade
so macht weiter und so fort und da ich
jetzt ja gerade meine bachelorarbeit
beim studium abgegeben habe und jetzt
quasi mehr oder weniger fertig mit dem
studium als ich muss anders klopp zu
machen und die note und kriege noch und
so weiter und so fort aber ich bin quasi
verleger deswegen bringe ich mir gerade
spanisch unter anderem bei ich bringe
gitarrespielen bei aber hauptsächlich
gerade klavier spielen weil ich einfach
bock habe sondern ein paar sachen zu
machen uns ein paar sachen zu machen in
denen ich die letzten drei vier jahren
nicht wirklich zeit habe wegen studium
youtube arbeitet ist das und jetzt
kriege ich immer so was von viele tipps
zugesendet und videos wie leute klavier
spielen und so und ich finde es einfach
mega cool als ich zeige euch jetzt mal
also sie hat der rapid gespielt deswegen
ich zeige euch mal wie weit ich gerade
fertig spielen kann also es ist nicht
gut oder so da irgendwas ich will nicht
angeben oder sowas und gottes willen
also ich kann doch gar nicht aber damit
ihr seht wo ich gerade stehe
[Musik]
ich hoffe man konnte irgendwie erkennen
dass es sich dabei um allen walker fake
handelt ich möchte mich einfach nur
musikalisch schon ein bisschen
weiterbilden und juckt eigentlich gar
keinen von der weiter mit nächsten video
ich fand dich einfach mal fragen was hat
dir die inspiration natürlich geben
überhaupt jetzt über anzufangen aber
nicht vergessen luca - shop.de 13
[Musik]
erfasst was hat mir die motivation dazu
gegeben youtube zu motiven tube zu
motivieren wahrscheinlich das sind so
fragen die ich schon 1000 mal
beantwortet habe aber natürlich kann
nicht jeder jedes video anschauen aber
das ist ja quasi diese frage hey du hast
ja ich mit youtube angefangen warum hast
du angefangen er langeweile
das war vor circa 56 jahren im herbst
und ich hatte einfach langeweile
das ist die komplette story wider
erwarten was eine story wie abu garda
gestorben und bei der vom teufel und er
musste pakt mit dem teufel schließt
wirtschaft gesund und auch wieder auf
die erde zurück wenn du youtube videos
macht nee ich hatte einfach nur andere
weide steinigen mich gerne dafür oder
lassen es vielleicht sein weil ich noch
nicht sterben will
es gibt viele fragen die ich sehr oft
gefragt werde und zwar auch die bin ich
auf meinen namen gekommen das war
einfach nur um macht jetzt frage hier
also mal diese beiden standard fragen zu
klären warum ich mich lieber angefangen
habe das war einfach langeweile und ich
habe meinen namen gekommen bin das war
einfach crafter wegen minecraft so der
crafter und kann
einfach weil ich unbedingt kräfte hatte
jaffé als anfangsbuchstaben ich wollte
cc haben so als beobachte ich früher cc
und dann habe ich überlegt was kann man
machen konnten heißt auch spanisch mit
oder irgendwie so war dachte ich so mit
kräften zusammen kräften danach ist mir
aufgefallen dass koller französisch
heißt oder nicht so die klügste
entscheidung
das ist mal sicher dieses eichhörnchen
dann geben wenn ich jetzt zu hause ein
video machen leute scheiß eichhörnchen
land und sucht müsse wir haben keine
nüsse in unserem garten aber was video
zurückzukommen das ist schön dass das
dein haus ist das ist drin der woche
ich weiß nicht ob ich das gerade richtig
gesehen habe habe ich glaube die haben
dort einen badmintonschläger einfach mit
voller wucht auf den boden geknallt also
wir schauen mal wie der schläger jetzt
aussieht
[Gelächter]
wisst ihr das verwirklichen zu eurer
schläger wieder nicht wahrscheinlich
eure mutter oder einen vater gekauft und
ihr houten einfach so offen boden habe
ich früher auch gemacht fand ich mega
kraft habe ich da mal ne ganz stark
gefühlt wo ich diesen schläger auf den
boden geschlagen der sein fach voll
kaputt
ja gut dass ich jetzt noch den schläger
dann auch noch boccia kugeln drauf
geworfen habe so krass war ich jetzt
nicht drauf ich verstehe das nicht
na ja die leute wissen ja schon wieder
so eine scheiße einsenders
wahrscheinlich höchstwahrscheinlich wird
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich aber eher wie ich habe
sich dann so zum abmachen hey du guckst
du die kamera muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen beschweren ich bin so cool dass
ich jemandem and road flinte den arsch
hoch schieben würde und dann abdrückte
alles kleid bekomme ich ja schon videos
1 gesendet wo babys beauty palace janko
und ich animiert werden und ich sitze
dort und scheiße übrigens aber wir
schauen jetzt mal wie das video so
weitergeht und ob julian khol wirklich
eine schrotflinte nimmt und mir in den
arsch knallt also ich weiß dass ich ab
und zu mal auf videos von dir und deiner
freundin reagiere und dass ich jetzt
auch sage dass ich den content nicht
wirklich feiert aber ich finde jetzt
auch bei mehrfacher überlegungen und dem
abwägen von vorteil nachteil chance
risiken muss ich ganz wirklich auf den
entschluss kommen lieber gegangen wo das
geht meines erachtens viel zu weit
also an dieser stelle muss ich sagen
mich warum kriege ich so videos 1
gesendet wo leute in übels kranker
hochskalieren geschwindigkeit irgendwas
machen
ich mache das jetzt auch mal
bei guten laut trailer mir jetzt meine
damen und herren da solltet ihr jetzt
noch alle machen die findet unter dem
video einen button eingeblendet
abonnieren klick darauf und wenn ich
schon abonnent seit wirkt auf die glocke
dann bekommen die benachrichtigungen
wenn ich aus hochladen freundin aber
direkt die nächsten da geht es
wahrscheinlich auch auf mein profil und
abonniert mich erstmal alles klar du
kriegst von mir auf jeden fall schöne
post vom staatsanwalt
warum wir so was eingesendet an der
tafel steht eins plus eins was kommt
raus
[Musik]
und ja ich hab was kommt raus günther
jauch in der disco wer kennt es nicht da
kommt einfach der günther jauch aus
disco aus
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen als ich mir
das video jetzt mal angesehen habe
beschweren kann ich mich dann davon wie
die meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass auf jeden fall mal nen
fetten leiche und haben wieder da wenn
ihr herz der luca reagiert sehen wollen
und schreibt jetzt mal in die kommentare
ob für euch das hauptschul liegt auch
der hit des sommers ist und sonst würde
ich jetzt sagen das was ihr vom video
das war's jetzt ihr vom video hier
können jetzt jemanden kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten meinen job aus checken
jetzt findet ihr zwei andere videos und
wenn ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr
auf die glocke klicken dann willkommen
die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]